lakovic 19 a fait chuter l'économie a
provoqué une forte volatilité sur les
marchés depuis le début d'année
comment se protéger de ces fluctuations
et des inquiétudes qui viennent avec
samedi la chapelle et planificatrice
financière bonsoir bonsoir
est ce que le pire est derrière nous
pouvez-vous nous souffler un peu nous
aider là nous aider à souffler justement
comme investisseurs c'est la question
sur toutes les lèvres puis j'aimerais
pouvoir vous et que oui le 23 mars
dernier c'est que le marché a atteint
son creux et que plus profiter de la
piscine du bon temps que rapide tumulte
mais malheureusement je n'ai pas trouvé
la boule de cristal pendant leur
confinement au contraire par contre on
ne peut pas le futur mais on peut
permettre s'intéresser aux leçons de
l'histoire
donc si on regarde ce qui s'est passé
dans les dernières crises boursières
on peut quand même constater que le cru
des marchés s'est étalé sur une période
de plusieurs trimestre habituellement
pendant une récession et donc pas
seulement quelques mois quelques
semaines donc tout à fait probable que
cette histoire se répète que les marchés
reculent encore à nouveau une correction
nouveau des actions mais donc c'est
tellement important de savoir si
finalement le creux on l'a atteint goubo
je pense que c'est vraiment plus
important pour les investisseurs
d'être préparés à naviguer en eaux
troubles et d'assumer qu'on est dans une
période où la volatilité est très grande
et marché avance de 2 ports recule d'un
pas
selon les annonces qu'on a sur un
potentiel vaccin sur l'ailé le succès de
l'ouverture des économies sur le nombre
de nouveaux cause de nietzsche et héros
dont les marchés seront très volatil et
c'est à peu près la caisse seule
certitude qu'on peut avoir
mais si on ne fume pas
la relativité comment on peut se
prémunir contre la volatilité des
marchés encore les investisseurs sont
impatients ils aimeraient avoir des
recettes miracles mais la recette de
base et le mans la même depuis plusieurs
semaines donc c'est de rester investi de
miser sur la diversification puis de ne
pas essayer de prédire le marché donc
quand on parle de rester investi
ça semble qu'on ait un conseil tellement
de base que j'ai répété plusieurs fois
et pourtant si on regarde les chauffards
mars 2020 au canada dans les fonds
communs de placement lieu pour plus de
14 milliards de dollars de rachats
naître et pour vous donner une idée en
2009 ça représente à peu près 80% le
chef de ce qui avait été vendue en fonds
communs de placement au canada donc
vraiment beaucoup de gens qui ont cédé à
la panique
pourtant peu de temps après le creux les
indices ont remonté et donc les gens qui
sont sortis leurs billes ont encaissé
des pertes majeures alors que ceux qui
ont maintenu une focus sur leurs
objectifs à long terme et miser sur la
répartition d'actifs
elles sont dans une meilleure posture
aujourd'hui puis ont récupéré la grande
partie leurs pertes
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
parce que de toute façon le répète à
chaque fois chaque fois qu'il ya des
chutes c'est pas le temps de vendre les
les gens assument leurs pertes à ce
moment là mais vous devez
continuellement le répéter on a presque
repris tout ce qu'on avait perdu depuis
le début de l'année sur les marchés
boursiers exactement
et puis en mars dernier ces sites comme
les l'anxiété était plus grande les gens
aussi étaient confinées à la maison donc
avait beaucoup de terre pour s'inquiéter
sur l'avenir de leurs placements donc
sur métier qui explique et autant de
gens qui ont quand même finalement eu un
comportement complètement irrationnel
d'un point de vue de l'investissement
est ce que la stratégie des achats
périodiques chaque semaine chaque deux
semaines chaque mois est
particulièrement approprié dans un
contexte de crise et leur goût oui même
si à très très long terme plus l'horizon
placement il est long - le moment où on
entre dans le marché que dame avoue être
significatif à long terme et pour les
gens qui ont un horizon plus qu une
tolérance au risque plus faible c'est
aussi une façon bien c'est l'anxiété et
continuer à investir parce que c'est le
conseil qu'il faut faire il faut quand
même continuer à acheter mais le faire
de façon intelligente donc actuellement
dépendamment de votre profil
d'investisseur
on peut dans le fond faire des achats
périodiques sur une période de six à
douze mois
ce qu'ils voient dans le fond vous
permet de profiter d'une hausse
potentielle et de vous prémunir contre
une baisse deuxième phase plus votantes
et légalement
puis un autre conseil que je voulais
absolument donner aux gens c'est que
s'intéresser pas seulement la volatilité
puis à la hausse et à la baisse des
marchés mais de regarder la répartition
de l'actif de leur portefeuille c'est la
clé c'est l'élément clé centrale qui
fait qu'à long terme notre portefeuille
de qualité va générer du rendement c'est
de s'intéresser à une bonne répartition
des types d'actifs des secteurs
d'activité parce que les secteurs sont
certains sont stricts défensif et nous
n'avons pas tous bien en même temps les
jouer la fille également donc bien
représenté au niveau des régions sur sur
le club
j'eus au fait en sorte qu on va se
donner un portefeuille de qualité qui
voit dans fonds résister aux intempéries
vous avez parlé de recueil un instant il
ya beaucoup de déposants qui ont vendu
leurs actions des fonds de travailleurs
ftq fondaction csn
que pensez vous de la réaction de ces
gens qui ont racheté beaucoup de leurs
actions mais je crois qu'elle s'explique
quand même facilement parce que dans les
dernières années le font l'effort je
peux quand même dire en m'intéressant
donc pour les gens surtout qu'ils sont à
l'aube de la retraite ou déjà la
retraite c'est très tentant d'encaisser
ligue 1 puis de vouloir dans le fond
retirer leurs billes ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que c'est des actions qu'on
doit considérer comme des actions dont
ce sont des actions canadiennes doivent
faire partie d'un portefeuille global
donc si vous êtes bien diversifiés que
vous êtes en période d'accumulation et
que dans le fond vous êtes posture
concentré en actions canadiennes par le
biais de la ftq csn parce que les
avantages fiscaux qui sont très
intéressants y a pas lieu de paniquer
pour les gens qui sont en retraite pré
retraite
donc ce n'est pas une mauvaise idée le
de procéder ou à chaud au transfert de
ces actions là parce que l'on annoncé
dans les derniers jours que le cours de
l'action avec peu baissé mais oui c'est
normal parce que c'était calculé partout
des rendements 2009 principalement qui
était une bonne année mais ça serait
surprenant alors que dans le futur le
cours de l'action
elles ne soient pas influencés par
l'économie loi qui va subir les
contrecoups convoite roger samedi la
chapelle merci merci bien
merci et bonne été